Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Ich bin kein Hacker, das ist klar. Nein. Ich wollte FIFA und UEFA helfen, diese Schnauze zu schliessen. Wenn ich die Fußballinstitutionen sehe, sehe ich viele Veränderungen. Das ist ein Geschäft, in dem alle sich sich verteidigen.
Er hat definitiv auch Fehler begangen, die jetzt auch zu ihm geführt haben, die man nicht so erwartet hätte von jemanden, der offenbar versiert im Umgang mit Computern zu sein scheint. Also über dieselbe E-Mail-Adresse zum Beispiel, das russische E-Mail-Konto von Artem Labatsurov angelegt. Das ist derjenige, die gefakete Identität, mit der ein Erpressungsversuch vonstatten ging, über den wir auch gleich noch sprechen müssen. Und mit derselben IP-Adresse, die zwar verschlüsselt war, aber es war eben die gleiche dann auch den Football Leaks E-Mail-Account bei diesem russischen Mail-Anbieter. Und da gibt es noch viele andere Dinge, da muss man dann tatsächlich ein bisschen graben, um die auch zu finden in Medien. Es wird wie immer ausreichend Links geben in den Show Notes dazu. Die Grundlage quasi der Fragen, die ich jetzt hier stelle. Bevor wir aber jetzt mal zu dem kommen, was da mit ihm passiert ist, rund um Auslieferungen an Portugal und Anklage dort. Deine Einschätzung, ist denn das Projekt Football Leaks jetzt vorbei?
Nein, vorbei ist es nicht, weil wir immer noch auf diesem riesigen Datenberg hier sitzen. Und weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob es am Ende nicht doch noch deutlich mehr Personen gibt als Rui Pinto. Das ist ja auch eine der großen Fragen. Er selbst sagt, er hat dieses Projekt nie alleine geführt. Wir haben auch einen Hinweis darauf, dass das möglicherweise stimmen kann, weil als er verhaftet wurde, ist uns nochmal ein weiterer Football Leaks Datensatz bzw. ein Dokument. Es war kein großer Datensatz, sondern mehrere Dokumente, die uns nochmal zugeschickt wurden.
Auf welchem Weg?
Das möchte ich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt zumindest noch nicht sagen, aber zumindest einen Weg, der auf jemanden hinweisen muss, der mit Football Leaks zu tun hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie er das gemacht haben könnte, gemacht haben sollte. Vielleicht hat er es irgendwie gemacht. Ich kann nicht schlecht beantworten. Aber das ist zumindest das, was Rui Pinto immer gesagt hat, dass er Football Leaks nicht alleine gemacht hat. Als ich ihn gefragt habe, wie ich mit seinen möglichen Mitstreitern irgendwann mal in Kontakt treten könnte, hat er mir damals gesagt, dass sie mit mir in Kontakt treten werden, wenn es so weit ist. Schauen wir mal, ob da noch was kommt oder nicht kommt. Aber was zumindest in den nächsten Monaten mit Football Leaks sicherlich zu tun haben wird und auch dort eine große Rolle spielen wird, ist der Prozess zum Rui Pinto. Wenn der Richter die Anklage der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft annimmt, dann wird es sicherlich relativ zeitnah zu einem Prozess kommen, in dem es noch einmal um die Aufarbeitung der letzten Jahre gehen wird. Davon ist jetzt auch noch mal abhängig, welche Vorwürfe tatsächlich zugelassen werden. Wenn man sich die Verhaftung und den Haftbefehl anschaut, ist das schon auf europäischer Ebene eine ziemlich skurrile. Und auch, um ehrlich zu sein, mal gucken, ob wirklich rechtstaatliche Vorgehensweise, die dort stattfindet. Der Haftbefehl selbst, mit dem Rui Pinto verhaftet wurde im Januar, beinhaltet ja nur Vorwürfe aus dem Jahr 2015. Also nur, in Anführungsstrichen. Dort geht es um vier oder fünf Fälle der möglichen Cyberkriminalität und um den Vorwurf der versuchten Erpressung. Bei dem Vorwurf der versuchten Erpressung muss man dazu sagen, dass zu keinem Zeitpunkt Geld geflossen ist. Pinto hat kein Geld erhalten. Warum auch immer nicht erhalten. Dementsprechend ist eigentlich dieser Vorgang – Pinto selbst bestreitet, dass er jemanden erpressen wollte. Die Firma Doyon Sports sagt, er wollte erpressen. Mal sehen, wie die ermittelnden Behörden das sehen. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es noch den Verein Sporting Lisbon, der Pinto den Vorwurf gemacht hat, dass Pinto Zugriff auf die Mailkonten bzw. offenbar auf die Daten von Sporting Lisbon hatte. Aber das sind die einzigen Vorwürfe aus dem Jahr 2015. Damit ist Pinto nach Portugal ausgeliefert worden. Im Zuge der Ermittlungen in Portugal sind dann offenbar noch weitere Fälle auf seinem Rechner gefunden worden, die aber eigentlich nach den rechtsstaatlichen Vorgängen in Europa nicht gefunden werden dürfen. Normalerweise darf sich die ermittelnde Staatsanwaltschaft bzw. die Polizei nur mit den Vorwürfen beschäftigen, die in dem Haftbefehl enthalten sind. Die Portugiesen haben dann im Zuge dieses Haftbefehls irgendwann mal um die Erweiterung des Haftbefehls in Ungarn gebeten, um möglicherweise weitere Straftaten aufzuklären. Sie sind dort im Prinzip in diese Grundthese reingelaufen, die es schon bei der Verhaftung gab, dass sie diesen Haftbefehl von 2015 nur aktiviert haben, um Zugriff auf möglicherweise weitere Straftaten von Pinto zu erhalten. Das wird man jetzt sehen, ob es wirklich Straftaten sind. Ich bin vor allem auch auf die Beweisführung sehr gespannt. Das ist ja das eine, Daten auf dem eigenen Rechner zu haben bzw. Daten dort vorliegen zu haben. Das andere ist die Beweisführung, wie diese Daten auf diesen Rechner gelangt sind. Dazu habe ich auch in der Anklage bislang noch wenig gesehen. In der Anklage gibt es zahlreiche Städte, aus denen offenbar ein Angriff auf bestimmte Datenbanken, Vereine, Kanzleien wie auch immer stattgefunden hat. Aber das waren Städte wie São Paulo, wie St. Petersburg, wie Hongkong, also alles Mögliche. Das kann auf der einen Seite passiert sein, wenn jemand mit VPN ins Internet geht und über einen Torbrowser seine eigene IP-Adresse verschlüsselt. Das ist die eine Theorie, die von der Staatsanwaltschaft kommt. Es gibt aber auch schlicht und ergreifend die andere Möglichkeit, dass es eben verschiedene Menschen sind. Das alles muss der Prozess zeigen. Deshalb glaube ich, dass rund um den Prozess das Ganze auch noch ziemlich spannend wird.
Jetzt sieht aber allein die Anklage sehr monströs aus. Anklagen sehen immer schlecht aus für den Beklagten. Das ist der Sinn einer Anklage. Aber wenn ich lese, dass Rui Pinto vorgeworfen wird, 147 Verbrechen begangen zu haben. Die Anklageschrift hat 195 Seiten. Ich gebe zu, ich habe sie nicht gelesen. Deswegen kann ich jetzt auch nicht da kontern, wenn du sagst, die Beweisführung ist dünn zu beweisen, dass es tatsächlich Rui Pinto war. Dann sieht es aber schon nach sehr deutlichen Vorwürfen aus. Gleichzeitig war ja diese Frage, wie kommt John, respektive Rui Pinto, an die Daten, das hing von Tag 1 über Football Leaks? Das habt ihr auch thematisiert. Das haben wir auch hier im Rasenfunk schon häufig besprochen. Das war aber vor allem für andere Medien, nach dem, was wir ja auch diskutiert haben und was man auch so lesen konnte, mit einer der Hauptgründe, Kritik an dem Projekt zu üben. Auch in Football Leaks 2 diskutiert ihr im Jahr 2018 nochmal darüber, wie ihr mit diesen Vorwürfen gegenüber Rui Pinto umgehen sollt. Findest du, ihr habt das ausreichend gekennzeichnet, dass die Herkunft dieser Daten sehr unsicher ist und aus einer illegalen Machenschaft kommen könnte?
Also ich glaube, mehr als das, was wir dazu gemacht haben, kannst du doch gar nicht mehr machen. Also wir haben das in jedem Artikel, also in jedem größeren Artikel, bei dem wir auch auf die Quelle hingewiesen haben, haben wir uns mit den Vorwürfen rund um Rui Pinto beschäftigt, zuletzt im November 2018 in dem Super League Artikel, in dem wir ein ganzes Bein drin haben, bei dem wir uns nur mit Rui Pinto beschäftigen und auch mit den damaligen Vorwürfen, die auch Salvador erhoben hat und die aus Portugal kamen. Wir haben im Dezember 2016 mit der ersten Football Leaks-Welle den kompletten Erpressungsversuch, wenn man ihn so nennen möchte, des Artem Lubosov, von dem wir jetzt wissen, dass es Rui Pinto ist, damals es aber noch nicht wussten, beschrieben und auch damals schon darauf hingewiesen, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass das jemand von Football Leaks ist, egal wer. Auch da bewegen wir uns ja in der Verdachtsberichterstattung und dem presserechtlichen Bereich. Wir können ja schlecht zu dem Zeitpunkt sagen, das ist John. So können wir nicht, weil er selbst bestreitet das, er selbst sagt, oder er hat es nicht bestritten, sondern er hat sich dazu nicht eingelassen. Das heißt, im Zuge der Verdachtsberichterstattung können wir aufweisen, es gibt diese E-Mail-Adresse, die auch von Yandex kommt, die auch mit Football Leaks zu tun hat, die möglicherweise eben auch eine Person von Football Leaks ist. Wir haben nur Kontakt zu einer Person, die befragen wir, die konfrontieren wir sauber mit den Vorwürfen und hören dann dazu, dass sie sagt, sie möchte, das sei lächerlich und sie möchte nicht zu allen Bezug nehmen, was irgendwie in den Medien ihr vorgehalten wird. Das stellen wir dann also entsprechend da und das war unsere Haltung, die wir bis heute verfolgt haben. Ehrlicherweise weiß ich gar nicht, ob im Nachgang, ob das alles so richtig ist, so viel Transparenz in einem solchen Projekt walten zu lassen. Vielleicht wäre es sogar besser gewesen, überhaupt nicht über die Vorwürfe zu sprechen. Ich spinne jetzt gerade rum, ich würde es beim nächsten Mal wieder so machen, aber ich wollte auf einen anderen Punkt hinaus.
Ja, auf den bin ich gespannt.
Ja, wenn du dir anguckst, wie die Offshore Leaks, wie die Paradise Papers, wie die Panama Papers, wie die Bahama Leaks abgelaufen sind. Das sind alles sehr große, gesellschaftlich extrem wichtige Enthüllungen, die etwas verändert haben, die sowohl etwas im steuerrechtlichen Sinne verändert haben, als auch eben gezeigt haben, wie immens anfällig Europa in der Steuerpolitik ist. Und trotzdem schwebt ja auch über diesen großen Enthüllungen durchweg der Vorwurf, dass diese Kanzleien von außen gehackt wurden. Also sowohl Mossack von Seckar als auch Appleby haben beide gesagt, sie seien gehackt worden. Da ist vielleicht dann, keine Ahnung, die Kollegen von ISZ haben einen etwas anderen Weg als wir gewählt, auch weil sie eben keinen, zumindest sagen sie, dass sie keinen direkten Kontakt zu ihrer Quelle gehabt haben und dementsprechend den Weg etwas anders gewählt haben. Wir haben hier von vornherein gesagt, dadurch, dass wir mit Pinto zu tun haben, müssen wir bestimmte Leitplanken für uns feststellen, um zu erklären, bis wohin kann man schützen und ab wo muss man als Journalist dann sagen, das Projekt ist zu Ende oder möglicherweise können wir mit diesem Projekt nicht weiter umgehen. Wir haben für uns ja dann auch irgendwann mal definiert, was sind eigentlich die Vorwürfe gegen ihn und wie hoch ist die gesellschaftliche Relevanz dessen, was er enthüllt hat oder was er dargestellt hat. Das führt dann unweigerlich auch zu den ganz großen Fragen der Digitalisierung und der Frage, wer eigentlich ein Whistleblower ist. Wer darf als Whistleblower bezeichnet werden? Wir haben den alten Begriff des Whistleblowers, also jemand, der aus einem Unternehmen kommt und in einem Unternehmen Dokumente gefunden hat, die er dann der Öffentlichkeit aufzeigen muss. Aber ist das wirklich die letztgültige Beschreibung eines Whistleblowers oder kann ein Whistleblower auch möglicherweise von außen kommen und Dokumente erhalten, die einen so hohen gesellschaftlichen Wert haben, dass man sie der Öffentlichkeit zukommen lassen muss und trotzdem für sich in Anspruch nehmen kann, dass man den Schutz des Whistleblowers genießt? Für uns ist es definitorisch so, dass Rui Pinto ein erhebliches Maß an persönlichen Risiken auf sich genommen hat, um der Welt zu zeigen, wie problematisch diese Fußballbranche tatsächlich ist und wie durchzogen sie von fragwürdigen, kriminellen Finanzflüssen und Machenschaften ist. Dementsprechend trifft für uns die Bezeichnung, dass Rui Pinto ein Whistleblower ist ziemlich genau zu. Es gibt einen Parallelfall, der ein bisschen drauf angelegt werden kann. Das ist Antoine Deltour, der die Lachsleaks damals an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht hat. Deltour ist bei einem regionalen Gericht als Krimineller verurteilt worden, weil er Daten aus einem Computer eines Unternehmens entwendet hat. Er ist dann aber von dem Europäischen Gerichtshof als Whistleblower klassifiziert worden.
Als erster seiner Art in der Form. Aber jenseits von diesen Interpretationsfragen, die uns sicherlich in der Zukunft noch weiter beschäftigen werden – das ist auch eine Diskussion, die wichtig ist, geführt zu werden. Auch der staatliche Umgang mit Whistleblowern im Unterschied zum Beispiel von Frankreich zu Deutschland und so weiter. Das sind Diskussionen, die sollen geführt werden und die sollen auch nicht nur anhand von Rui Pinto geführt werden. Aber wenn wir uns jetzt allein mal den Datensatz angucken, den ihr habt, oder die Datensätze, die ihr bekommen habt, gibt es denn auch, wenn da persönliche Nachrichten zum Beispiel mit dabei sind? Da erinnere ich mich, dass im Football Leaks 1 zum Beispiel aus direkten Chats von zwei Personen zitiert wurden. Kann es denn dafür überhaupt einen legalen Weg gegeben haben, diese Daten zusammen? Spricht nicht alles dafür?
Naja, die Frage ist, inwiefern wir das bewerten sollten. Was bedeutet eine illegale Datenbeschaffung oder nicht? Für uns als Journalisten ist das Presserecht maßgeblich. Und das Presserecht sagt, dass wir auch mit mutmaßlich illegal erworbenen Daten arbeiten können, solange wir eine Person nicht dazu anstiften oder dazu anleiten.
Und das habt ihr auch nicht getan.
Also es ist zu keinem Zeitpunkt. Die Trennlinie zwischen Rui Pinto und mir, was das angeht, war brutal und ist auch bis heute. Ich benutze immer diesen Satz, dass ich sage, dann hätte ich ihn sicherlich irgendwann mal gefragt, ob er mir was zu Uli Hoeneß.
Oder sonst was besorgen kann. In Football Leaks 1, noch bevor ihr euch zum ersten Mal trefft, schreibt ihr zum Beispiel, ich habe ein kleines Geschenk für dich und dann geht es um deutsche Spieler in Dokumenten, die angehängt sind. Es fällt ja auch auf, dass sich der Fokus der Leaks von Portugal über Spanien zur Premier League und immer mehr auch in einen Bereich, der dann auf einmal auch den DFB beeinflusst, der die DFL beeinflusst und eben deutsche Vereine trifft. Also von außen betrachtet sieht das schon so aus, als hätte es da eine Interessenserweiterung gegeben, von seiner Seite zumindest.
Den DFB und die DFL?
Naja, wenn wir über Super League sprechen, dann sind wir ja in der DFL respektive und in der DFB-Geschichte rund um die Uhren, das war doch auch aus Football Leaks Beständen oder nicht?
Okay, gut, dann streichen wir den DFB – Ja, auch die DFL kannst du streichen, weil die Sachen, die wir zu Super League hatten, hatten keinen, also kamen...
Nur von den Vereinen?
Ja, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es dort irgendeinen Link zu einer deutschen Gruppierung gab. Diese Sachen können auf, oder ich vermute zumindest grob, dass diese Sachen einen anderen Ursprung hatten. Ich kann es aber nicht nachhalten oder belegen, aber du kannst ja sehen, wie viele Mannschaften involviert waren, in die Gespräche der Super League. Also da ist keineswegs eine Zuordnung auf eine Örtlichkeit oder einen Verein oder eine Person gegeben. Nein, aber um das nochmal sehr, sehr klar zu sagen, ich habe mit Rui Pinto zu keinem Zeitpunkt über irgendwelche Themen geredet oder ihn gebeten, irgendwelche Themen für uns zu suchen oder zu finden. Das wäre strafrechtlich Wahnsinn. Und so sehr ich meinen Job liebe, gibt es bestimmte Grenzen, die ich ganz sicher für diesen Job nicht aufs Spiel setzen würde. Und das ist so eine, die ich zu keinem Zeitpunkt übertreten habe.
Er soll sich jetzt eben in Portugal vor allem für das Hacken in Portugal verantworten. Er soll unter anderem laut Anklageschrift Sporting Lissabon, dem Portugiesischen Fußballverband, zwei Anwaltskanzleien, den Südamerikanischen Fußballverband, die FIFA, die UEFA und sogar das Büro des Staatsanwalts gehackt haben. Das wird ihm vorgeworfen. Wirst du denn in Portugal auch vor Ort sein, um über diesen Prozess zu berichten? Oder hältst du dich daraus jetzt raus? Denn es könnte ja sein, dass du Teil dieses Prozesses bist. Du bist der Einzige, über den Rui Pinto seine Daten in die Öffentlichkeit bringen konnte.
Wie gesagt, bislang habe ich keinerlei Hinweise darauf, dass ich in irgendeiner Form Teil eines Ermittlungsverfahrens bin oder dass gegen mich oder gegen uns als Medienunternehmen ermittelt wird.
Du wurdest auch noch nicht angefragt von den portugiesischen Behörden?
Ich wurde weder angefragt noch befragt, noch in irgendeiner Form informiert. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich habe, wie gesagt, die portugiesische Justiz zigmal, um Erlaubnis gebeten, mit Pinto vor Ort sprechen zu dürfen, in Interviewen zu dürfen, ihn auch zu den Vorwürfen befragen zu dürfen. Das heißt, im Umkehrschluss, wenn die portugiesische Justiz mich hätte sehen wollen, wäre es relativ einfach, mir einfach die Erlaubnis zu geben, mit Pinto zu reden, dann wäre ich nämlich im Land gewesen. Das haben sie aber strikt abgelehnt im letzten halben Jahr. Mein Plan ist es, den Prozess sehr eng zu begleiten. Das ist eine der zentralen Aufgaben, die ich jetzt hier eigentlich auch für die nächsten Monate für mich sehe, die mich auch auslasten wird, wenn es dann dazu kommt. Ich vergleiche das immer so ein bisschen mit dem Prozess rund um Ante Shapina und rund um die Matchfixer in Bochum aus dem Jahr 2010, 2011. Ich vergleiche es nicht von der Kriminalität, sondern von der reinen Masse. Damals war es auch so, dass über 300 Spiele manipuliert gewesen sein sollen, dass sich Verdachtsfälle der Manipulation auch in der Anklageschrift aufgetaucht sind. Wenn man sich am Ende anguckt, was für ein Promillesatz Shapina und Co. verurteilt wurden, also wie wenig Spiele am Ende hängen geblieben sind und wie lange der Prozess dann auch andauerte inklusive aller Revisionen und Revisionsverfahren. Da bin ich gespannt, was von dieser schieren Masse, die sich am Anfang wiegt, wie so eine 147 bzw. so 152 mutmaßliche Straftaten, die in der Anklage aufgeführt sind. Wenn man sich das anguckt, ist das schon gewaltig. Man kommt dann nach dem ersten Lesen aber auch relativ schnell zu dem Punkt, dass dort beispielsweise die Straftat Cyberkriminalität im Umkehrschluss fast zweimal gewertet wird, weil du auf der einen Seite Cyberkriminalität hast und auf der anderen Seite den Straftatbestand des Briefgeheimnisses, also des Bruchs des Briefgeheimnisses, die sich aufdröseln, aber dort die gleiche Wertigkeit haben. Ich glaube, der Hauptangriffspunkt ist nach wie vor die versuchte Erpressung. Wenn die versuchte Erpressung so nicht gehalten werden kann, dann bin ich gespannt, wie es sich mit den anderen Vorwürfen verhält. Weil bei den anderen Vorwürfen brauchst du eigentlich eine Belegkette oder eine Indizienkette. Das heißt, du musst nachweisen können, welches WLAN benutzt wurde, du musst nachweisen können, welcher Computer benutzt wurde, du musst nachweisen können, von wo nach wo der Einbruch stattgefunden hat. Also jetzt aus der Reihenlogik all der anderen Hacking-Fälle, die wir in den letzten Jahren irgendwie hier gesehen haben, ohne zu sagen, dass Rui Pinto ebenfalls gehackt hat. Aber aus all den Fällen war schon sehr ersichtlich, dass Cyberkriminalität in der Aufklärung keineswegs so einfach ist. Und ich persönlich die ganze Zeit auch da, der der Fragefolge, warum sich die Justiz komplett dermaßen fokussiert auf die Aufklärung dieser Straftaten und auf keinen der Anfragen auch der anderen Justizbehörden Europas eingeht, die ja mit dem Material arbeiten wollen, weil sie feststellen, dass es in Europa zahlreich andere Bereiche gibt, die mit dem Material ernsthafte, große Straftaten aufklären können und eine Unterstützung der Aufklärung dieser Straftaten dort stattfinden könnte, ohne verharmlosen zu wollen – man sollte so früh am Morgen nicht so viele Fremdwörter nutzen – ohne verharmlosen zu wollen, dass die Vorwürfe gegen Rui Pinto schon absolut ausreichen, um ein Verfahren anzustreben, wenn sie sich so bewahrheitet.
Wenn sie sich so bewahrheitet, ja, aber die Vorwürfe sind durchaus schwer wegen. Das bringt uns ja aber auch zur Rolle des Spiegels als Institution generell im Umgang mit der Darstellung, wie zum Beispiel dieser Prozess abläuft. Da ist mir zum Beispiel ein kleines Detail aufgefallen, an dem wir vielleicht ganz gut euren, nicht Interessenskonflikt, aber den schmalen Grad beschreiben können, den da der Spiegel auch in seiner Darstellung gehen muss. Und zwar beziehe ich mich auf die Darstellung des Anwalts von Rui Pinto, das ist William Bourdon. Das ist der Anwalt unter anderem von bekannten Whistleblauern, aber auch von Michel Platini, der rund um die WM-Vergabe 2022 in Korruptionsverwürfe verstrickt ist und ebenfalls von Lamine Diac, Ex-Präsident des Leichtathletik-Weltverbandes, der wegen Korruption von den französischen Behörden angeklagt wurde. Den Hinweis auf die anderen Whistleblower im Portfolio von Bourdon, den finde ich. Den Hinweis auf Platini und Lamine Diac, finde ich in den Büchern nicht.
Weil jeder Punkt hätten wir wahrscheinlich mit aufführen müssen, ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich bislang mit Bourdon über diese Fälle, also sehr bewusst auch nicht gesprochen habe, weil ich genau in diesen Interessenkonflikt nicht kommen wollte. Ich wollte von ihm weder wissen, wie seine Vertretung von Diac, noch wie seine Vertretung von Platini abläuft schlicht und ergreifend, weil ich, wie er selbst darüber schreiben und diesen Anwalt, der dann noch so ein bisschen zwischen den Stühlen möglicherweise sitzt, in dem Fall gar nicht damit, also mit meiner eigenen Rolle gar nicht behelligen möchte. Weil meine eigene Rolle da ja auch schon so ist, dass ich natürlich sehr viel auch über Pinto weiß und mit ihm zu tun hatte und da für mich eben eine Grenze gesetzt habe.
Aber wäre das für die Leser nicht wichtig zu wissen?
Ja, deswegen habe ich gerade gesagt, möglicherweise ist das ein Punkt, über den wir hätten auch ausführlicher auch debattieren müssen, ob man Platini mit rein nimmt, also zumindest Platini mit rein nimmt. Die Jagd ist ja weit weg vom Fußball, obwohl ich jetzt gerade am Wochenende Abend im Spiegel eine Enthüllungsgeschichte über die beiden Diags gehabt, an der ich mitgearbeitet habe, bei der es mich manchmal in den Fingern gejuckt hat, Boudin anzurufen. Aber mit Fußball hat die Jagd nicht zu tun. Trotzdem, bei Platini hätte dieser Hinweis möglicherweise mit rein gesollt. Ich weiß persönlich aber nicht, wie das Mandatsverhältnis zwischen Boudin und Platini ist. Ich kenne dort die Hintergründe nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob er ihn ausschließlich in dem FIFA-Fall vertritt oder ob er ihn grundsätzlich vertritt. Das ist etwas, womit ich mich einfach zu wenig beschäftigt habe, weil auch Platini für uns ja nicht die allergrößte Rolle in den Football Leaks gespielt hat. Und trotzdem ist es ein Punkt, das sollten wir in Zukunft aufnehmen, dass wir Platini da möglicherweise mit reinschreiben. Aber manchmal ist es auch eine Darstellungssache. Für die Erklärung, dass Platini auch mit von Boudin vertreten wird, müsste man sofort auch einen relativ großen Erkläransatz wählen, um in dem Zuge zu erläutern, was Platini eigentlich vorgeworfen wird und was er…
Ist jetzt eine stilistische Frage, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine weiterführende Information.
Ich weiß, dass wir damals darüber diskutiert haben, aber alle, die auch der Meinung waren, dass Platini eine so untergeordnete Rolle in den Football Leaks gespielt hat, dass er eigentlich dort keine Rolle spielt und dass es bei Boudoir auch eine sehr klare Chinese Wall gibt. Er hat das damals auch Pinto früh gesagt, dass er gesagt hat, er hat dieses Mandat und dass er die beiden Mandatseiten nicht mehr miteinander in Berührung bringen möchte. In Wahrheit haben das zahlreiche Anwälte und oft genug schreiben wir genau über diese Interessenkonflikte. Von daher werden wir über den Punkt noch einmal nachdenken, dass es ein valider Punkt ist.
Ist denn mal Geld vom Spiegel zu Rui Pinto geflossen? Für die Daten, für Reisen, für Essen?
Ich habe das ja schon zigmal gesagt, dass wir weder für die Daten noch für die Dokumente in irgendeiner Form Geld bezahlt haben. Wenn es Auslagen oder sonstiges gab, dann haben sie sich komplett im Rahmen der Richtlinien dieses Hauses hier bewegt und das machen wir ja nicht nur mit Rui Pinto, sondern das machen wir dann auch mit dem einen oder anderen geschätzten Informanten, den wir…
Kannst du mir den Rahmen dieser Richtlinien nennen, weil ich kenne ihn nicht? Also, dass man dann nur für Reisen und Spesen zahlt oder was ist der Rahmen?
Genau, also ich bin ein großer Freund davon bei Spesen zu sagen, dass das etwas ist, was zwischen dem Medium und zwischen der Quelle behandelt wird und die Öffentlichkeit in dem Rahmen eigentlich auch im höchsten Transparenzsinn nicht zu bewegen hat, weil das Ausgaben sind, die sich in einem solchen kleinen Rahmen bzw. so geringen Rahmen bewegen, dass sie keinerlei größere oder nennenswerte Faktoren für einen Zusammenhang zwischen Journalisten und zwischen Quellen spielen können. Also nein, ich werde über diese Dinge nicht sprechen, weil ich auch nicht weiß, ob mein Unternehmen möchte, dass ich über Spesenrichtlinien spreche. Es ist etwas, was die Unternehmen dann ja auch für sich selbst definieren. Aber wie gesagt, es sind Kleckerbeträge.
Okay. Ich stelle die Frage deshalb. Ich würde mich ja auch nicht an so Kleinigkeiten aufhängen, wenn ich nicht einen größeren Kontext dazu hätte, der die Frage rechtfertigt. Und ich stelle die Frage deshalb, weil wir bei Rui Pinto einen Hacker, Whistleblower, Informanten, was auch immer haben, der eben nicht in einem fest angestellten Verhältnis zu einem Unternehmen ist, sondern der irgendwie seinen Lebensunterhalt in Budapest finanzieren muss. Glaubst du, dass John tatsächlich nur über das An- und Verkaufen von antiquarischen Dingen getan hat, so wie er es dir gesagt hat?
Ich bin ein Faktenmensch. Wir sind bei Glauben geraten werden. Schwierige Punkte. Ich glaube grundsätzlich vieles nicht. Vieles, was mir Informanten erzählen, vieles, was ich lese, glaube ich zunächst einmal nicht. Und dann versuche ich, mich an Inhalten abzuarbeiten. Und ich kann nur sagen, ich kenne die Lebensräumlichkeiten von Rui Pinto. Oder ich kannte sie. Ich weiß, wie seine Lebensführung ausgesehen hat. Und nichts von dem, was ich dort in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren gesehen habe, hat darauf hingedeutet, dass das ein wohlhabender Mensch ist. Genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Der hat in echten Bruchbuden gehaust und gelebt. Der hat, ich glaube, dass ich ihn in dreieinhalb Jahren in zwei unterschiedlichen Jeans gesehen habe. Mit einem paar Schuhe im Winter und ein paar Schuhe im Sommer. Und jetzt möchte ich nicht, dass du mir als nächstes wieder sagst, dass das romanhaft ist, was ich sage, weil das ist die – so ist herumgelaufen. Der ist dreieinhalb Jahre mit einer Lederjacke durch die Gegend gerannt, egal ob es Winter oder Sommer war. Das teuerste, was er besessen hat, war sein Fernseher, den er sich irgendwann mal gekauft hat. Also für diesen Lebensstandard braucht man nicht so richtig viel.
Kann es möglich gewesen sein?
Ja, es kann aber auch möglich sein, dass er irgendwann mal geerbt hat. Es kann auch sein, dass er irgendwann mal Geld aus irgendeinem anderen Bereich erhalten hat. Die Grundannahmen, woher oder wie er seinen Lebensunterhalt am Ende finanziert hat, sind vielschichtig. Ich verweise auf das, was er selbst dazu sagt. Auch als er verhaftet wurde, hat die Polizei auf seinem Konto 4.500 Euro gefunden. Das war alles. Bislang habe ich auch nichts dazu gehört, dass sie irgendwelche Geldflüsse festgestellt hätten, die belastbar wären.
Gut, es gab natürlich auch mal Geldflüsse. Das liegt jetzt allerdings schon im Jahr 2013 zurück. Aber da waren auf seinem Konto erst 31, 67 Euro und dann irgendwann 227.000 Euro. Das war eben die Erleichterung der Caledonian Bank auf den Cayman Islands. Das ist aber eine Geschichte, die jetzt vor den Football Leaks stattgefunden hat.
Und man muss den Zusatz dazu sagen, die er zurück überwiesen hat.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber dennoch, wenn ich erst im Laden was klaue, wollen wir uns an der Sache jetzt nicht aufhängen.
Ich muss dazu noch einen Satz sagen, weil natürlich alle diese Dinge so in der Plastizität, wie du sie gerade darstellst, ein gewisses Licht entwickeln oder beziehungsweise jemanden auch in eine Verteidigungshaltung drängen bzw. in eine Erklärungshaltung auch ihn hinein drängen. Aber das sind doch auch nur die Fakten, wo du sagst, du bist…
Oder ist es jetzt ungerecht, dass ich das zitiere?
Nein, nein, nein, gar nicht. Ich will es nur erklären, weil zu den Fakten gehört natürlich auch noch eine zweite Seite. Wenn jemand tatsächlich in einer Bank einbricht und etwas geklaut haben soll und dass ein rein illegaler Vorgang wie auch immer geartet ist, dann bekommt man dafür in der Regel ja ein Strafverfahren. Man bekommt eine gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung und wird verknackt. All das ist im Fall von Rui Pinto nicht passiert. Es gab ein außergerichtliches Settlement zu dieser Geschichte, warum auch immer. Das sind halt einfach Punkte, bei denen ich dann auch an meine Erklärungsgrenzen stoße, wenn ich ihn dann gefragt habe, warum wurdest du nicht verhaftet? Ich meine, das ist ein Bank-Einbruch, wenn es denn so ist. Das ist ja etwas, was schwerwiegend ist und bei dem man dann auch im Zweifel ein paar Jahre einsetzt, gerade wenn es um eine sechsstellige Summe geht. Dann wollte er mir das oftmals nicht beantworten, sondern hat dann gesagt, ich habe eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung, ich kann dazu nicht sagen. Da kann man sich dann tausend Sachen drunter vorstellen und ausmalen, aber am Ende ist es eben dann doch nicht so einfach zu sagen, dass er eine rein kriminelle Handlung gemacht hat, weil möglicherweise gibt es dazu auch noch andere Erklärungen, möglicherweise gibt es dazu noch eine zweite Ebene, die ich bislang zumindest nicht verstanden habe. Ich möchte da zumindest noch den abschließenden Satz machen, dass die Football Leaks – das ist ja ein Projekt, bei dem du nicht nach einem Handbuch agierst. Das hätte ich mir oft gewünscht, dass wir in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren dieses Projekt irgendwo ein Handbuch gehabt hätten des investigativen Leak-Journalismus, das uns klar definiert, was richtig, was falsch ist, ohne dass wir all unsere eigenen Fehler machen oder all unsere eigenen Erfahrungen machen und sie immer wieder neu justieren und darstellen, sei es jetzt von der Inhalts- oder von der Darstellungsseite oder vom Umgang mit einer Quelle. Das ist ja auch etwas, was man aus dem ganz normalen Alltag herausmacht, aus Erfahrungen, die in dem Moment ankommen, die man gemeinsam macht, aus Diskussionen, die man hier hat und aus – in Wahrheit – Try and Error. Auch das gehört dazu. Wir haben bestimmte rechtliche Vorgaben, an denen wir uns mit zig Anwälten orientiert haben. Dazu kommen die moralisch-ethischen Vorgaben, die dieses Haus für sich definiert. Und in diesem Rahmen haben wir versucht, uns zu bewegen. Ich finde es jetzt gut, dass wir uns einfach ein bisschen Zeit nehmen, um über solche plastischen Sachen zu sprechen, wie der ist doch ein Bankräuber. Das ist das Einfache, das mir mit der Aussage begegnet wird, der ist doch ein Bankräuber, das kann doch kein Whistleblower sein. So, und dann fängst du an, das Ganze aufzudröseln. Du fängst an, die nächste Metafrage zu stellen und die dritte Metafrage. Und dann sitzt du da oftmals irgendwann am Ende eines Abendessens und die Person, die einem gegenüber sitzt, sagt, ja, das sind schon irgendwie spannende Fragen, wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht, wie ich die beantworte. Und in dem Bereich bewegen wir uns ja hier jetzt gerade auch.
Ja, apropos spannende Fragen und die Frage, wie man sie beantwortet. Ihr habt dann nach der Enttarnung von John alias Rui Pinto, habt ihr auch in zwei Tagen, an zwei Tagen, ein Interview mit ihm geführt. Daraus entstammen auch all die Zitate, die im Intro zu hören waren. Das war dann auf dem YouTube-Kanal der Sportschau noch verfügbar. Warum habt ihr aus zwei Tagen Interview nicht viel mehr veröffentlicht? Ihr müsst doch stundenlang mit ihm gesprochen haben. Gab es mal die Überlegung zu sagen, wir stellen das aus Gründen der Transparenz, weil ihr müsst euch als Haus für euren Umgang mit den Football Leaks, gerade weil es ja eben dieses Handbuch dafür nicht gab, ja auch verantworten und selbst auch schützen? Gab es mal Überlegungen, davon mehr zu veröffentlichen? Ich war ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass es aus zwei Tagen nur so wenig rauskommt.
Also grundsätzlich ist ja die Aufgabe eines Journalisten, das Wesentliche darzustellen und nicht Unwesentlichen zu versinken. Wir hatten das Gefühl, dass wir aus dem Zusammenspiel der TV-Aufnahmen, der ARD bzw. des NDR und unserem eigenen gedruckten Interview, was damals, glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Seiten lang war, genug Informationsmaterial dem Leser geliefert haben, das noch im Rahmen des Konsumierbaren gewesen ist.
Na gut, du sprichst hier mit einem Podcast. Vielleicht habe ich da andere Maßstäbe. Aber verstehst du so ein bisschen, aus welcher Richtung meine Frage kommt? Ich hatte das Gefühl, das wäre jetzt mal ein Zeitpunkt gewesen, der erste öffentliche Eindruck von Rui Pinto und für jeden, den es interessiert. Also dass du jetzt nicht zwei Stunden Interview um 20.15 Uhr in der ARD sendest, das ist ja völlig klar, aber für jeden, den es interessiert, hätte man ja noch mehr verfügbar machen können zum Beispiel.
Ach ja, das sind ja dann auch alles Kapazitätsfragen. Also wir haben ja vorhin über die Länge des Buchs gesprochen. Es gibt Leute, die mich jetzt anschreiben und sagen, ihnen hätten 120 Seiten des Buchs gereicht. Andere melden sich und sagen, bitte mach sofort jetzt ein drittes Buch. Wir wollen weiterlesen. Das Ganze reicht noch nicht aus. Die Spannbreite aller Menschen wirst du mit Journalismus niemals bedienen können. Und zu sagen, dass man eine ungeschnittene Fassung eines Interviews mit einem Whistleblower online stellt als Submittel und sagt, hier kann jeder noch weiter sich das angucken, ist in der Tat vielleicht eine Überlegung, die man machen kann, wenn man hier mit einer 20-köpfigen Mannschaft oder sonst was dran sitzt, die das Ganze ja dann auch nochmal bearbeiten, aufarbeiten. Die Kapazitäten, also personelle Kapazitäten haben wir hier im Moment nicht. Wir haben damals, ich erinnere mich wirklich noch sehr, sehr lebhaft an diese Phase, wie wir gekämpft haben, dieses Interview mit allen EIC-Partnern zu koordinieren und den Zeitpunkt zu koordinieren, die Autorisierung durchzubekommen und das zu veröffentlichen. Da ist manchmal dann auch die, also vielleicht auch jetzt deine Anspruchshaltung an uns, nur begrenzt zu erfüllen, weil wir, wie gesagt, dann jetzt auch nicht, wir sind kein reines Football-Leaks-Unternehmen, sondern es gibt da halt auch schon viele andere Sachen, die man noch drumrum machen muss. Und wie gesagt, ich kann nicht zehn Leuten sagen, bitte mach das auch noch.
Dann ist ja noch etwas passiert, was ich vorhin schon mal angerissen habe, nämlich die Aufdeckung der Fäschungen von Klaas Relotios. Hat dieses Ereignis, was im Dezember letzten Jahres stattgefunden hat – und jetzt ist gerade ein Buch dazu erschienen von Juan Moreno, 1000 Zeilen Lügen – hat das deine Art und Weise verändert, wie du mit deiner eigenen Berichterstattung umgegangen bist?
Ja, im Endeffekt hat das ja schon vor Klaas schon längst stattgefunden, dass wir uns ins Besondere, wenn es um solche Geschichten wie es die Football Leaks aktuell sind, dass wir da nie alleine arbeiten, dass wir immer im Team arbeiten, dass wir uns gegenseitig versuchen, auch zu kontrollieren. Wir haben bei Football Leaks ja nicht nur ein reines Football Leaks Spiegel-Team, das damit arbeitet, sondern auf der anderen Seite auch 100 weitere – mittlerweile sind es ja fast 100 Journalisten, die im europäischen Ausland damit zu tun haben. 80 waren es für die Football Leaks 2, die jede einzelne unserer Enthüllungen noch mal viermal drehen und sich angucken, die Fragen an Rui Pinto übermittelt haben, die über das hinausging, was ich mit Pinto besprochen habe, die immer wieder auch so klare Sparring-Partner und vor allem Kontrollinstanzen für unsere eigene Arbeit sind und waren. Wir haben hier zumindest bei unserem Team die klare Haltung, dass wir große Investigativgeschichten nicht mehr oder nicht alleine machen, nicht nicht mehr, sondern nicht alleine machen. Das gilt aber für die ganzen letzten Jahre, weil wir uns einfach dann auch gegenseitig versuchen zu helfen und zu unterstützen, damit man nicht irgendwo einen blinden Fleck hat und damit hier nicht irgendwas durchrutscht. Das sind jetzt aber die völlig normalen Kontrollinstanzen, die wir haben. Das geht ja deutlich über das hinaus, was dort als Vorwurf über Klaas schwebt oder was dort als Vorwurf geäußert wurde.
Wobei es natürlich damals die Kontrollinstanzen auch gab und man im Nachhinein sagen muss, die haben in großen Teilen ihre Arbeit als kontrollierende Instanz nicht wirklich erfüllt.
Aber das ist was völlig anderes als die Art, die wir zum Arbeiten verwenden. Klaas war zu 99 Prozent alleine unterwegs. Viele seiner Geschichten hat er, seiner großen Reportage, hat er ganz alleine gemacht, oftmals auch ohne einen Fotografen, mit einem Dokumentar, der angebunden war, offenbar an das Ressort. Aber ich persönlich möchte für mich gar nicht so sehr in Anspruch nehmen, weiter über Klaas zu reden. Dafür ist jetzt der Huren der Experte, der darüber geschrieben hat. Das Haus hat einen großen, ich glaube auch in vielerlei Hinsicht, schonungslosen Report hingelegt und sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, wie uns das passieren konnte. Ich kann hier für mich, für unseren Investigativsektor sprechen und dort kann ich halt einfach nur sagen, dass wir deutlich intensiver auf die Beleglagen hinweisen, die Beleglagen auch drehen und versuchen, da auch selbstkritisch mit umzugehen, wenn uns etwas misslinkt. Das war ja in den letzten Tagen auch nachzulesen. Ich bin von einer eigenen Geschichte eingeholt worden aus dem Jahr 2014, bei der wir damals in der Tat ein zu großes Risiko mit dieser Geschichte gegangen sind. Ich bin immer noch überzeugt davon, dass diese Geschichte stimmt, aber wir haben eine Geschichte veröffentlicht, bei der wir einen Teil zumindest nicht mehr schriftlich belegen können.
Also es geht um verschobene WM-Gruppenspiele von Kamerun und im Nachhinein hat derjenige, mit dem du darüber gesprochen hast, Wilson Rai Perumal, ein Matchfixer, hat dann im Nachhinein gesagt, das was er dir gesagt hätte, wäre erst nach dem Spiel passiert, was du aber im Artikel so beschrieben hattest, dass er das angekündigt hätte. Es findet jetzt ein Eignis statt, was dann auch eintraf.
Ich finde das halt Wahnsinn, dass wir mittlerweile ja dann auch alles irgendwie vermengen mit Relotius und ich habe mich dann auf einmal jetzt auch in…
Naja, dieser Artikel wurde auch von der Relotius-Kommission überprüft. Deswegen gibt es da schon eine Verbindung.
Aber die Relotius-Kommission prüft ja hier zig Artikel von unterschiedlichen Personen. Die Relotius-Kommission, das ist vielleicht eine Namensfrage, dass man die Relotius-Kommission als Relotius-Kommission nennt. Man könnte sie auch Spiegel-Kommission oder sonst was nennen. Die Personen sind ja nicht eingeschossen auf Relotius. Sie haben nur mit Relotius begonnen, aber es geht ja hier. Wir diskutieren unsere eigenen Standards. Wir diskutieren darüber tagtäglich auch mit dieser Kommission, wie wir Dinge besser machen können bzw. wie wir mit Dingen besser umgehen können, wo wir vielleicht auch unseren eigenen Sinne schärfen können. Bei dem Artikel, über den wir gerade sprechen aus dem Jahr 2014, ist es ja so, dass ich eine eidesstattliche Versicherung eines Kollegen habe, der meine Darstellung damals gesehen hat. Ich habe einen Wettüberwacher, mit dem ich kurz nach dem Spiel gesprochen habe und ihm erzählt habe, wie meine Informationslage rund um Pedro mal ausgesehen hat bzw. rund um diesen Chat. Das hat oftmals gereicht. Man hatte zwei unabhängig voneinander agierende Personen, die sich zumindest darauf rekurrieren konnten. Bei denen haben wir dann gesagt, dass es eine halbwegs valide Beleglage ist, mit der wir uns in einem Risikobereich befinden. Aber wir wollen hier die Wahrheit schreiben. Wir wollen hier das schreiben, was stattgefunden hat. Also gehen wir auch an der Stelle ins Risiko. Aus heutiger Sicht – und das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt in der Glaubhaftmachung von Artikeln, in der wir uns jetzt aktuell finden, in einer Zeit, die das auch deutlich stärker einfordert – ist dieser Artikel in der Tat schwierig zu begründen. Ich könnte ihn nur begründen, wenn ich den Chat in der Form hochhalten könnte. Das kann ich aber nicht, im Übrigen, weil das auch zigmal falsch geschrieben wurde. Ich konnte es auch schon 2014 nicht. Das ist vielleicht der größte Unterschied zu all diesen Klaas-Vorwürfen und Relozius-Vorwürfen. Ich habe alle Instanzen in diesem Haus meine Beleglage vorgelegt und habe gesagt, das ist noch das, was ich habe. Das ist das, was für die Beleglage spricht.
Bevor der Artikel veröffentlicht wurde, meintest du?
Bevor der Artikel veröffentlicht wurde. Ich war damals in Brasilien.
Das ist ja für Außenstehende fast noch das Erschreckendere, dass dann dennoch dieser Artikel online ging, oder im Heft gedruckt wurde, Entschuldigung, auf dessen Grundlage ja dann auch die FIFA-Ermittlungen eingeleitet hat. Und das ist ja ein schwerer Vorwurf, dass ein WM-Spiel verschoben wird von einer Mannschaft, weil da mehrere Spieler, sogenannte, Zitat, faule Äpfel wären. Das war der Titel dieser Geschichte. Das ist ja fast nur frappierender, dass man das damals schon wusste, dass die Beleglage aus eurer Sicht schwierig ist und trotzdem dieser Artikel erst veröffentlicht wurde. Und dann im Nachhinein, auch obwohl er sehr früh dann schon in Kritik geraten ist, hat es jetzt fünf Jahre gedauert, bis der Spiegel sich dazu nochmal geäußert hat und das gerade gerückt hat. Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt schwerwiegender, als wenn dir die Belege danach irgendwie abhandengekommen wären.
Das sind aber Fragen, die sind größer als sie jetzt hier mit mir zu diskutieren. Das sind ja auch Hausfragen, um die es dabei geht, die zu stellen sind. Du hast gerade die Faule Äpfel angesprochen. Im Übrigen, das ist ja ein Zitat, das ich belegen kann. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich das Gespräch mit Perumal erträumt habe, sondern es geht um die ersten eineinhalb Sätze, in dem Artikel gestritte ich bin. Bei denen ich sage, sie haben so stattgefunden, mein Zeuge, der das eidesstattlich für sich hat, sagt ebenfalls, die haben so stattgefunden. Und es gibt einen Wettüberwacher, der sagt, der Buschmann hat mir sehr früh davon erzählt, ich weiß es auch. Das ist die Beleglage auf der einen Seite. Wir haben aber auf der anderen Seite das Dementi von Perumal. Und wir haben eben nicht diesen vorderen physischen Teil des Chats. Wenn man sich dann aber anguckt, dass du gerade gesagt hast, der schwerwiegende Vorwurf ein Spiel sein manipuliert. Das ist ja der Vorwurf, den Perumal erhoben hat, den wir auch im Nachhinein noch belegen können. Er hat ja gesagt, dass alle drei Spiele von Cameroon manipuliert seien.
Er hat ja gesagt, es ist dort im Nachhinein gesagt.
Definitiv. Er hat es ja gesagt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich den Vorwurf alleine geäußert hätte, dass diese Spiele manipuliert waren. Trotzdem, um das nochmal abzukürzen, das Risiko bei der Geschichte war zu hoch. Wir sind dieses Risiko zu hoch eingegangen. Wir hätten im Prinzip genau, wie du es jetzt gerade sagst, damit arbeiten sollen, dass wir darstellen, dass Perumal behauptet, diese Spiele seien manipuliert. Dass er behauptet, dass die Spieler von Cameroon dort involviert waren. Ich glaube, sieben schwarze Schafe hat er genannt oder sieben faule Äpfel. Ich habe es nicht mehr genannt. Aber dass er das behauptet hat, das hätte vollkommen gereicht. Es hätte den Einstieg nicht gebraucht. Es war ja in der Logik, dann ging diese Geschichte ja weiter, dass Perumal drei Monate nach der Geschichte Unterlassung gegen uns gefordert hat. Kurz darauf hat Perumal sein gesamtes Facebook-Profil gelöscht. Er ist nie wieder mit seinen Anwälten auf uns zugekommen. Wir haben nie wieder etwas von dieser Geschichte gehört.
Er hatte aber natürlich auch andere Sorgen. Er war ja selbst in Finnland zu der Zeit, mit dem du mit ihm geschrieben hast. Korrigiere mich, wenn ich da gerade was durcheinander werfe. Er hatte ja durchaus seine eigenen juristischen Dinge gerade zu tun. Und was man aus anderen Quellen lesen kann, wo ich mich jetzt aber nur auf eine Quelle stütze, da gibt es einen sehr langen Blog-Eintrag, hatte er auch finanzielle Probleme zu der Zeit und musste sich über sehr spitze Voraussagen vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Also es könnte auch daran gelegen haben, will ich damit einfach nur sagen.
Natürlich kann es daran gelegen haben. Im Übrigen, um das nochmal gerade zu rücken, man braucht keine finanziellen Ressourcen für eine Unterlassungserklärung. Eine ein-zweilige Verfügung im ein-zweiligen Verfügungsverfahren zu erwirken, dafür bedarf es einer eidesstattlichen Versicherung, die man abgibt und sagt, dass dieser Chat so gelaufen ist, wie man ihn auch darstellt. Und dann läuft ein Anwalt los und holt das Ding ein. Es würde dann erst finanzielle Ressourcen nach sich ziehen, wenn es in einer Art Hauptsache-Verfahren oder so etwas gehen würde. Perumal hat schon den ersten Punkt nicht gemacht, obwohl er mit einer renommierten deutschen Kanzlei damals auf uns zugekommen ist. Es gibt bei dieser Geschichte ja zahlreiche Punkte, bei denen man von einem strittigen Ablauf sprechen kann. Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, einfach weil wir gesagt haben, dass wir diesen physischen Bereich des Schätzens nicht haben. Dass wir gesagt haben, wir nehmen die Geschichte raus, was ich für richtig halte. Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass wir uns nicht diese Geschichte nochmal angucken und auch nochmal zu dieser Geschichte recherchieren werden.
Du hättest, nachdem was berichtet wird, unter anderem bei Übermedien, bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung, Leiter der Investigativabteilung des Spiegel werden sollen. Da soll es interne Widerstände gegeben haben. Und das Ende der Geschichte ist jetzt auch, du wirst nicht Leiter dieser Abteilung. Hängt das nur mit diesem einen Artikel aus dem Jahr 2014 zusammen?
Also was mein Chefredakteur in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt hat, was ich bestätigen kann, ist, dass ich auf die Beförderung verzichtet habe, dass ich sie unter diesen Umständen auch nicht wahrnehmen möchte. Mir ist nicht bekannt, dass irgendjemand hier Widerstände gegen mich geäußert hätte, die in irgendeiner Form mit meiner Arbeitsweise zu tun gehabt hätten. Dass dieser Artikel hier auch im Haus strittig war und hier besprochen wurde. Das hat mehrere Gründe, dass im Zuge einer solchen Beförderungsfrage ein 5 Jahre alter Artikel dann nochmal herangezogen wird. Das hat eine Koinzidenz, über die man, wie auch immer, geartet nachdenken kann. Aber es ist für mich auch, um ehrlich zu sein, unerheblich, weil ich an der Stelle dann auch für mich sage, dass das Reporterleben ein sehr tolles Leben ist. Ich freue mich weiterhin auf dieses Reporterleben und glaube, dass ich mit dem Pinto-Prozess mehr als genug zu tun haben werde. Dementsprechend ist dieser Weg, den wir hier eingeschlagen sind, der richtige.
Und verzeih mir die eine misstrauische Nachfrage dann noch. Es bezieht sich jetzt aber nur auf den Faule-App für Artikel aus dem Jahr 2014. Es gab keine anderen Artikel, in denen Zitatlagen, Belege für vorgebrachte Fakten, für Behauptungen gefehlt hätten, an denen du beteiligt gewesen wärst.
Ich habe mich mit der Kommission zu einem weiteren Artikel, mit dem ich mit Ihnen darüber geredet habe. Das konnte ich, glaube ich, sehr gut erklären. Es ist ja jetzt einfach so, dass diese Nachfragen im Zuge der Untersuchung auch von außen gekommen sind. Ich habe versucht, das so gut wie möglich darzustellen.
Kannst du sagen, welcher Artikel das ist?
Nein, es ist unerheblich. Ich habe mir meine Beleglage dargestellt und dieser Artikel ist in keiner Art und Weise weiter behandelt worden. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt.
Also keine weiteren Artikel, bei denen noch irgendwann aufploppen konnte. Da hat jetzt ein Beleg gefehlt oder es wurde ein Zitat verwendet, was nicht im Nachhinein noch mal nachrecherchiert werden kann von der Dokumentation.
Was heißt denn, die Frage versteht, inwiefern soll ein Zitat nachrecherchiert werden, das vielleicht, keine Ahnung, vor zehn Jahren oder sonst was abgegeben wurde? Also ich finde, die Perumal-Geschichte, da gibt es einen validen Punkt. Es gibt eine schriftliche Auseinandersetzung, bei der jemand sagt, ich habe hier einen Beleg, bei dem ich nachweisen kann, dass die schriftliche Auseinandersetzung später stattgefunden hat, als der Redakteur es behauptet. Und der Redakteur sagt, ich ziehe hier mehrere physische Quellen heran, die erklären sollen, dass meine Darstellung stimmt. An der Stelle ist es ein strittiger Punkt, bei dem ich selbst sage, das Schriftliche überwiegt. Also das heißt, solange ich diesen Chat nicht habe, was ja auch noch nicht ausgeschlossen ist, dass wir ihn irgendwann mal bekommen, aber solange ich diesen Chat nicht habe, finde ich es besser, diese Geschichte dann auch aus dem Netz zu nehmen oder diese Geschichte nicht weiterhin als strittige Geschichte auch über dem Haus schweben zu haben. Aber ich meine, wir dürfen jetzt, finde ich, auch diesen Berufsstand, den wir haben, nicht sämtlich überhöhen. Wir haben alle ganz oft mit Geschichten zu tun, bei denen man zwei Quellen, drei Quellen hat, die einem etwas sagen, mit denen man zu tun hat, den man dann in dem Moment, in dem man die Recherche macht, ja auch vertrauen muss, weil man dann an dem Punkt eine Übereinstimmung hat oder weil man an dem Punkt eine valide Information hat, die zu dem jeweiligen Zeitpunkt Sinn ergibt. Ich habe meine Beleglagen, dem Spiegel in ausführlichster Deutlichkeit immer gezeigt, mit ihm besprochen, sei es jetzt mit meiner Ressortleiterin, mit der Rechtsabteilung, mit der Chefredaktion, mit Kollegen, an denen ich daran gearbeitet habe. Deswegen, ja, misstrauische Fragen bin ich in meinem Berufsstand gewöhnt, aber ich glaube, dass auch eine gewisse Form von Fairness irgendwie auch an einen selbst auch noch herangezogen werden darf.
Fair enough, wie man so schön sagt im Englischen. Wir sind jetzt schon zehn Minuten über der Zeit. Würdest du mir noch fünf Minuten geben, um über die Rezeption der Football Leaks und vielleicht einen möglichen Ausblick zu sprechen? Hast du die noch? Wie würdest du denn jetzt rückblickend die Rezeption in Deutschland beschreiben? Bist du zufrieden mit dem, was sich jetzt auch verändert hat durch die Football Leaks?
Schwierig. Daran messe ich mich nicht. Ich messe meine Recherchen nicht daran, ob sie am Ende für eine ausreichende Rezeption oder für eine ausreichende Veränderung in der Gesellschaft gesorgt haben. Das können wir gar nicht. Ich habe es gerade versucht, anklingeln zu lassen. Wir sollten den Berufsstand der Journalisten auch nicht dauerhaft überhöhen. Wir sollten ihn nicht auf die allerhöchsten Podeste stellen. Wir sind weder Politiker noch Richter noch Staatsanwälte. Wir stellen die Welt so dar, wie sie sich in dem jeweiligen Augenblick ergibt oder wie sie sich uns zeigt. Wenn am Ende die Gesellschaft etwas anderes daraus machen will, wenn die Gesellschaft weiterhin Lust hat, das Treiben des Fußballs in der Form zu begleiten, wenn Politiker weiterhin den Wert von Fußball höher einschätzen als möglicherweise die Kontrolle dieser Branche, dann ist das etwas... Womit ich lebe. Womit ich leben muss.
Es ist natürlich der Whistleblower wichtiger. Also weißt du, so komme ich zu der Frage, wenn Rui Pinto sagt, er ist ein bisschen enttäuscht.
Und deswegen wollte ich halt den nächsten Schritt machen. Ich habe vor ein paar Tagen das Buch von Edward Snowden zu Ende gelesen. Das ist jetzt auch nicht ein Jubelbuch über die Auswirkung des Whistleblowings rund um staatliche Überwachung. Das ist auch ein Buch, das sich sehr kritisch und selbstkritisch damit auseinandersetzt, das sich eigentlich relativ wenig verändert hat, sondern stattdessen eine Zunahme staatlicher Überwachung stattfindet. Insbesondere, weil wir uns alle mittlerweile dem Smartphone ausliefern, weil wir uns alle Alexa oder sonst was in unsere Häuser stellen, weil wir uns auf eine Art und Weise vernetzen und digitalisieren, die jeden unserer Schritte transparent machen und darstellen. Wenn Rui Pinto sagt, dass ihm das alles nicht ausreicht, habe ich das auch im letzten Jahr schon verstanden. Er hat mir das in aller Deutlichkeit gesagt, dass er glaubt, dass jetzt die nächste Stufe seines Projekts stattfinden muss. Und das ist die Stufe des Weggehens von der rein öffentlichen Wahrnehmung hin zu einer Unterstützung staatlicher Organe. Deswegen hat er ja über so einen langen Zeitraum auch versucht, eine Anbindung an Behörden und an Autoritäten zu finden, um dort zu unterstützen. Das vergisst man ja immer in dieser ganzen Gemengelage. Aber Pinto ist im Prinzip wenige Tage verhaftet worden, bevor er in einer Art Zeugenschutzprogramm nach Frankreich sollte. Das war alles zu dem Zeitpunkt schon relativ festgezuhrt. Er hatte die klare Aussicht, dass er in Frankreich als Whistleblower die französischen Behörden hätte unterstützen sollen. Wenige Tage vorher ist er von den ungarischen Behörden auf Druck der portugiesischen Staatsanwaltschaft oder Generalstaatsanwaltschaft verhaftet worden. Dementsprechend für ihn war dieses Projekt nicht an der Stelle zu Ende, dass wir ein Football Leaks 2 veröffentlicht haben, sondern eigentlich hätte es dort anfangen sollen. Er hätte dort die Möglichkeit ergreifen sollen, Stadtliebebehörden zu unterstützen.
Es muss ja jetzt auch noch nicht das Ende des Projekts sein. Trotzdem möchte ich diese eine schleifend bindende Frage dann noch zum Abschluss stellen. Wenn wir jetzt mal kurz zurückblicken auf den Beginn von Football Leaks bis jetzt, würdest du im Nachhinein nochmal alles, was du in deiner Rolle als Journalist und Berichterstatter gemacht hast, genauso machen?
Ich wäre ja verrückt, wenn ich das jetzt auch nur ansatzweise mit einem Ja bezeichnen würde. Ich glaube, mit jeder Woche, die wir hatten, haben wir hier in unserer Reflektionsgruppe darüber gesprochen, was wir hätten verändern können. Und das fängt an mit der Art, wie wir mit Daten arbeiten. Das fängt an mit der Klassifikation von Daten. Das fängt an mit den Systemen, die wir dafür wählen. Aber das geht natürlich auch dann zu den großen Themen, wie – keine Ahnung – dem Umgang mit dem Whistleblower, möglicherweise dann auch der Fragestellung, ob wir dieses Projekt, ob es in der Tat nicht früher hätte zu Ende sein sollen, sein können. Das sind aber Fragen, die kann ich gar nicht beantworten, sondern die umtreiben mich. Die umtreiben mich, weil ich mir dann ja auch die Frage stelle, was eigentlich mit Pinto gewesen wäre, wenn wir im Januar 2018 gesagt hätten, das war es jetzt, wie er sein Leben gestaltet hätte. Aber das sind Fragen, die kriege ich gar nicht verändert. Da kann ich dann für mich vielleicht bestimmte Punkte rausnehmen oder kann für mich im Umgang mit Informanten dann auch in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren so viel gelernt wie in meiner ganzen beruflichen Zeit vorher nicht. Dieses Projekt war so intensiv oder ist intensiv. Dieses Projekt hat uns alle sowohl körperlich als auch an intellektuelle Grenzen gebracht, weil wir immer wieder im Minutentakt mit Entscheidungen konfrontiert waren, die wir vorher vielleicht so noch nie getroffen haben. All das in der Gemengelage – ich habe das nochmal während des Schreibens des Buches gemerkt, wie mich das aufgewühlt hat an manchen Punkten, wenn ich mir überlegt habe, wie müde, wie kaputt, wie vielleicht auch einfach durch wir an manchen Stellen waren und trotzdem dann eben mit der nächsten Enthüllung konfrontiert waren, mit der nächsten Entwicklung konfrontiert waren. Das ist ja kein Projekt gewesen, das wie bei anderen Geschichten mit einer Geschichte abgeschlossen war. Dann waren drei Wochen Pause und dann hat man die nächste Geschichte gemacht, sondern das ging hier dreieinhalb Jahre Schlag auf Schlag. Und wir alle diskutieren jetzt auch darüber, wie wir bestimmte Dinge auch in Zukunft in unseren Prozessen dann nochmal anpassen, verändern würden. Also insofern dafür war es sehr gut und dafür ist es immer noch sehr gut, dass wir unsere eigenen Arbeitsweisen nochmal ganz erheblich dadurch schärfen konnten und können.
Apropos Schlag auf Schlag, Apropos Mühde, ich habe dir jetzt 17 nicht vereinbarte Minuten geklaut. Ich möchte an der Stelle danken, dass du dich jetzt schon zum vierten Mal sehr ausführlich im Rasenfunk meinen Fragen gestellt hast. Wir hatten auch schon Q&As, wo die Hörerinnen und Hörer die Fragen gestellt haben. Danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, trotz der vielen Anfragen, die es bestimmt gibt und eben der Dinge, die du jetzt zu tun hast. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, widmet euch auch den anderen Tribünengesprächen. Auch das Tribünengespräch zum FIFA-Prozess hängt so irgendwie mit der Konstellation des Sujets. Dann doch auch mit den Football Leaks zusammen, kann ich euch sehr ans Herz legen. Ansonsten unterstützt den Rasenfunk, wenn ihr möchtet. Hinterlasst uns Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk in der Schlusskonferenz, dem Kurzpass oder hier im Tribünengespräch. Macht's gut, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.